[Musica]
a sera la sera ma se era una sera
sarò telegrafico
tele che nasce il giro almeno per i
primi standard o una mamma che ha 92
anni e questa mamma che ora di buona
salute ma lei non è mai stata d'accordo
con il lavoro che faccio mai e ogni
volta che faccio una fiction a me è
capitato anche ultimamente che non fatta
una qui a bari ma
quanto costa strada dice
e dico ma costa
4 milioni 4 milioni si no anche quattro
e mezzo quattro e mezzo ma è una fiction
servi servono i soldi
non era meglio costruirci un reparto
d'ospedale con questi quattro milioni e
mezzo
ma
il racconto serve a che
intrattiene intrattiene quando ha fatto
bene perché quadro fatto di merda sono
solo soldi buttati
costruisci un reparto d'ospedale questi
soldi
perché gli ospedali salvano le vite il
racconto non salva le vite
provato a dargli torto
anche perché un racconto alla fine che
è una roba un viaggio fra un signore qui
che vuole una cosa qui no che c'è un
desiderio giusto e c'era solo una serie
di ostacoli fra due questo e questo
obiettivo è tutto qua non solo ma è
tutto finto quel signore corre dei
rischi
per salvare la fanciulla dal drago ma
lui è finta una fanciulla finta drago e
filtro
e non solo
il racconto è pure costoso
5 milioni ma poco st 10 20 50
voglia reparti l'ospedale
oddio non è sempre stato così costoso
racconto perché perché non è vero perché
all'inizio i tempi dei tempi un certo
poeta dal nome eschilo i suoi racconti
costavano pochissimo dove arrivano il
teatro di epidauro si sedeva leggeva le
sue tragedie e le 16.000 persone
16.000 in piedi per cinque ore
pomeriggio perché c'era la luce non
c'era amplificazione ascoltavano le sue
tragedie quindi forse qualcosa doveva
esserci no
ma perché secondo voi 16.000 ateniesi
stavano lì ad ascoltare è stato che si
trovavano esattamente
forse perché parlando lui de roi siccome
adorano un po eroi perché anche in
qualche modo anche loro erano poi i
tempi degli eroi greci sarà questo no
eppure
noi non siamo tanto distanti da loro
perché noi ma lo stesso da 50 secoli
fatto esattamente nello stesso modo
forse anche noi visto che ancora ci
piacciono delle tragedie di eschilo
c'entriamo qualcosa con quegli eroi
forse siamo stati errori anche noi
magari da piccoli a quattro anni da 5 a
i presenti qui
erano tutti dei piccoli eroi giusti
forti coraggiosi che c'erano molto
preciso il loro compito quello che
volevano fare azioni eroiche
subito dopo siamo stati tutti presi a
calci in pancia
e qualcuno ci ha fatto capire che
volevamo di meno di quello che pensavamo
di valeri
questo c'è forse un po turbato ma siamo
comunque cresciuti siamo diventati
adulti siamo in grado di capaci di
lottare di combattere no
ma non per quello che è giusto siamo in
grado di combattere soltanto per ciò che
è utile
per ciò che conveniente
perché combattere per qualcuno che ha
bisogno di aiuto
no quello lo lasciamo fare agli eroi
perché gli eroici hanno coraggio e noi
magari ci identifichiamo dei racconti
con gli eroi perché quel giorno ora giu
ma perché noi ci identifichiamo in
questi racconti visto che questi eroi
non esistono e l'obiettivo per cui
lottano non esiste nemmeno quello
forse dipende da come siamo fatti
pensate che noi siamo esattamente come
erano diecimila anni fa
mammiferi di branco aggressivi non siamo
predatori però siamo pronti a a
inseguire una preda per 50 km di corsa
prima di stramazzare al suolo siamo
attrezzati per questo possiamo possiamo
resistere 70 giorni senza mangiare e 19
giorni senza bere
siamo in grado di avere una forza immane
è anche un grande coraggio e purtroppo
purtroppo a quel tempo serviva il
coraggio perché gli aggressori erano
molto pesanti bisognava battersi e
siccome noi siamo
pianificati per uccidere a volte
dovevamo farlo per sopravvivere
però in realtà non siamo tanto diversi
da come eravamo allora perché anche
allora come adesso l'uomo non vuole
soffrire
non vuole rischiare dei dispiaceri
e quindi nel momento in cui sorgono le
città l'uomo si rende conto che se ci si
mette tutti insieme ci si organizza
magari si fa un esercito ed esercito può
difendere la città dagli aggressori
esterni e quindi l'uomo è sollevato dal
fatto di doversi difendere da solo e è
un dispiacere eliminato poi scopre che
ci sono anche degli aggressori interni
nelle città rapinatori ladri
allora l'uomo si inventa la polizia e
anche lì si toglie la responsabilità di
dover rispondere personalmente agli
aggressori
e così per ogni azione rischiosa per il
quale l'uomo è attrezzato e pianificato
è pronto da un punto di vista neuro
endocrino muscolare
nasce un istituzione che lo solleva da
questo compito
bello no e il progresso
il progresso dell'uomo sembra essere
impostato solo su una frase che dice
eludere ogni forma di dischi acer e per
cortesia
ed è quello che facciamo
e lodiamo ogni forma di dispiacere il
problema è che quando li vediamo il
dispiacere
perdiamo qualcosa
perché se siamo attrezzati per
combattere
ci accorgiamo che il combattimento che
la lotta non è semplicemente qualche
cosa che serve per sopravvivere
e chiunque qui dentro si sia trovato a
lottare anche virtualmente con qualcuno
e ne sia uscito malconcio sa che ne dà
una lotta si esce felici se si legge ma
non si esce infelici se si perde è
perché
guardateli vengono fuori tutte le ferite
su dati bagnati lesionati sanguinati ma
nel volto hanno una fierezza
una specie di libidine quella fierezza
si chiama
autostima
sentite come dolce questa parola
questa autostima è qualcosa che ci rende
ci rende sereni con noi stessi no
se abbiamo delle aree dove sappiamo che
dobbiamo volare perché se non vogliamo
queste ali non è che si limitano ad
altre pizze stare lì come 22 mantelli
sprofondiamo nella depressione
ma voi direte ma reali non servono
soltanto a combattere ea creare servono
a provare l'ebbrezza del volo
perché se avete ali e le spiegate anche
se poi è rischioso volare perché vi
impallinano perché arriva un rapace
comunque se avete delle ali
voi provate l'ebbrezza del volo in quel
momento capite qual è il motivo per cui
sito al mondo
se il padreterno o o chiunque ci sia
lassù ma dato delle ali
voi capite perché
è giusto beh
vabbè ma comunque polare rischioso e io
non voglio volare perché comunque il mio
progetto umano è eludere il dispiacere
eludere il rischio per cui che faccio
sto tranquillo sotto le coperte e
sorrido e sono sano e salvo giusto
sbagliato perché quel sorriso il sorriso
dell'impiccato perché se l'uomo è e
pianificato per agire
non può rifiutarsi se avevo pianificato
per agire e non lo fa la rinuncia a
questa lotta lo riempie di rabbia
e questa rabbia non può essere sfocato
all'esterno perché nel momento in cui
spiegata sfogare la rabbia l'esterno che
succede fate danni anche gravi
ma se questa rabbia sfogata all'interno
trovate danni ancora peggiori
perché fate altrove stessi e non è solo
depressione perché date pressione solo
l'inizio poi arrivano i sintomi arrivano
le malattie
arrivano le gastriti nelle infiammazioni
e anche di peggio
è che fate
cosa fare in quel momento
un bel racconto
come racconta si è un racconto ma perché
un racconto perché un racconto ti
permette identificando di un eroe
mentre lui combatte contro il drago per
salvare la faccia ti permette di sentire
come se tu stessi lì con lui anzi no
senza di lui sei tu che sai combattendo
contro quel drago in realtà se stai sul
divano di casa dura davanti a netflix
con la coca cola non rischi lui non è
non ebbe nessun rischio e noi contenti
nel momento in cui si identifichiamo e
lui nel momento in cui pulp.it chiamo
con lui
che combatte
ritrovamo pace la rabbia pavia il nostro
sistema endocrino si rimette in moto e
abbiamo la stessa o quasi quasi
sensazione che avremmo avuto se avessimo
combattuto noi lì con lui
ed ecco che con buona pace di mia madre
forse qualcuno
che potrebbe arrivare in ospedale magari
ci arriva un po dopo
perché il racconto lo salva voi dite ma
vabbè ma questo non può dire che un
racconto salva delle vite questo non
bastano mai avete ragione un racconto
non salva delle vite o perlomeno questo
non basta
ma il racconto fa altre due cose
importantissime
la prima è
c'è da un apprendimento
se un apprendimento perché noi scopriamo
assistendo a un racconto identificandoci
con un eroe che le roi per quanto possa
essere picchiato per quanti calci in
faccia possa prendere da ogni colpo
l'eroe impara qualcosa
è perché mi pare qualcosa
anche in quel momento capisce che le
uniche occasioni per crescere sono
quando si soffre e se un uomo è
cresciuto e la storia della somma delle
sue cicatrici e le sue ferite
dai successi
non imparare niente
i successi sono soltanto così una
spazzolata la vostra vanità e dalle
sconfitte che imparate una cosa bella
del racconto è che mentre l'eroe
tartassato di colpi quando si rialza e
un uomo migliore perché grazie a queste
ferite e migliorato anche noi siamo
migliorati con lui
noi miglioriamo insieme a lui e se
l'eroe lascia quel racconto migliore di
come era quando è entrato anche noi ci
sentiamo migliori e quanti film della
vostra vita sentite che che vi hanno
lasciato migliori dopo che davate visti
che non eravate la stessa persona prima
di quella che eravate dopo la proiezione
questo apprendimento cosa ci insegna
ci insegna che la crescita non può
essere gratuita è legata alle sofferenze
ma questa è la vita voi direte va beh
abbiamo capito ma anche questo non basta
a far sì che il racconto sabit ed evita
infatti c'è un'ultima cosa che forse la
più importante di tutte
oltre all'apprendimento
oltre all'insegnamento il racconto ci dà
un modello un modello un esempio
quando ci identifichiamo con l'eroe che
si mette lì a combattere contro qualcuno
soltanto grazie alle sue azioni eroiche
sembra che quel signore lì ha certo
punto smetta di combattere ci prende per
le braccia e ci dice ehi tu
che stai facendo
perché non prende in mano la sua vita e
noi quel momento diciamo no io io voglio
eludere il dispiacere perché è così che
fanno gli uomini da sempre da 50 secoli
e nel momento in cui diamo questa
risposta ci rendiamo conto dell'unico
grande
insegnamento che ci viene dato e cioè
che a forza di eludere il dispiacere
l'uomo ha finito per eludere anche il
piacere
a forza di stare alla larga
dalle possibilità di rischiare l'uomo è
stato alla larga dalla gioia la gioia di
crescere e di diventare più forte che
saldo più scaltro più potente
la gioia di poter diventare in atto
quello che sa di essere impotenza
e di sopra tutto questo anche una de
coccio come mia madre ha dovuto dire beh
sì forse messa così e racconto può dare
qualche utilità ma tu non riesci a
vergognarti di aver comunque scelto un
lavoro utile sacrificabile no ma ma non
me ne vergogno
e se l'ho scelto sai perché l'ho scelto
perché quando ero bambino ho preso tanti
ma tanti tanti calci in faccia
e tu eri presente
e lei mi ha detto sì è vero
hai preso tante sberle se
ne prese tante
ma nessuno ci capiva niente con te
a me invece sarebbe voluto libretto
d'istruzioni
e io non ce l'avevo
e non volevo rischiare fatte male più di
quanto già tanti altri non ti faceva
e io ho detto ma quel libretto di
istruzioni non esiste e se esistesse ci
sarebbe scritta soltanto una frase
dell'unica pagina
soltanto se rischi
riuscirai a crescere abbastanza da poter
essere un modello per qualcun altro e
aiutare tante persone come te che non
avevano il coraggio che tu hai avuto a
prendere la vita nelle loro mani
grazie al lungo viaggio
del racconto
[Applauso]